passez à rachel legrain trapani qui
s'est fait insulter cette semaine sur
twitter twitter c'est un autre sujet il
ya de tout et du moins bon ben voilà il
s'est fait insulter parce que la pauvre
à celle de grains trapani et bien là
huit ans de plus que son petit chéri
footballeur et donc la traite de cougar
est ce que ça vous choque ou pas
regardez c'est l'un des couples les plus
glamour du moment le champion du monde
de foot un bavard et miss france 2007
rachel legrain trapani
une histoire qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois et qui suscite beaucoup de
réactions positives de la part des
internautes
mais d'autres sont étonné de la
différence d'âge des deux amoureux alors
que benjamin bavard a fêté ses 22 en
mars dernier rachel a quant à elle
soufflé ses trente bougies l'été dernier
un écart de 8 ans qui a poussé certains
états à traiter rachel de cougar au
début ça me faisait mal au coeur
après je me suis dit qu'on ne peut pas
plaire à tout le monde du côté de
benjamin pavard ces commentaires n'ont
aucun impact selon elle benjamin une
liste en moquent ils à cette insouciance
que les hauts murs n'ont pas toujours en
tout cas peu importe les commentaires
cette belle histoire nous prouve une
fois encore que l'amour n'a pas d'âge on
va faire du futur elle retraçait d'une
telle aubaine qui a pété les plombs a
parlé également également également
également de deux têtes john mais là un
mot ça vous choque
sinon ça me choque pas du tout moi je
l'aï vu ce matin au téléphone je les
appelais a été touché et oui elle est
sale saleh blessé au début leur relation
maintenant elle a 30 ans il en a 22
c'est le seul homme avec qui elle est
sortie qui est plus jeune qu'elle s'est
arrivé qu'une fois elles l'aiment
ils sont au dessus de tout ça c'est pas
une cougar à coup bien à 30 ans n'est
pas les cougars déjà je compte bien
répondre à ça c'est pas une habitude non
elle a juste évoqué dans la presse que
ça l'avait blessé au départ mais c'est
tout et c'est la presse qui a repris sa
et qui a refait toute une polémique
autour de tout ça mais on a un coût
guerre pour certains au début ça me
faisait mal au coeur après je me suis
dit qu'on pouvait pas plaire à tout le
monde voilà c'est ce qu'il a dit en mai
- on a on a l'exemple avec brigitte mc
ren est sombre il faut pas répondre à ça
va s'étendre jusqu'à d'intro et une
cougar non mais tient une femme et ça
fait l'admiration entre guillemets du
monde
en tout cas le respect une femme plus de
plus pure est plus âgée que son copain
il faut pas qu elle s'abaisse à faire ça
en fait il faut reprendre la phrase de
rené char le poète à me voir ils
s'habitueront il faut pas commenter ça
il faut pas commenter ça elle doit vivre
ce qu'elle vit et ne pas s'abaisser à
twitter ce que twitter c'est quand même
la halle
dupas corps en gueule alors en d2 les
bills qui se venge qui sont lâches qui
se cache derrière faut pas répondre à ça
parce que du coup ça fait une polémique
alors qu'en fait la polémique
non mais peu importe oui mais ses fans
répondent aliments pendu à une question
dans une interview c'est tout elle n'a
pas fait polémique
elle est très douce très gentille c'est
dommage qu'elle se fasse attaquer
gratuitement comme ça et c'est pas elle
qui a répondu c'est normal